[Music]
Ufafe can you do Yeah Yeah Yeah Toeisha
00 Yesterday
e 6 e
You guys are adding crap so that
you can live
ah ah ah
And I haven't done it
[Applause]
Retired from work  Even if I do, communication with society will be poor.
No one will look at me. If that
kind of situation continues for a long time,
my feelings will drop, and
I will not have the energy to do anything good anywhere.
[Music]
I'm worried about getting older.
After all, my biggest worries are how
healthy I can maintain my current health. I'm looking forward
to what I'm doing with this team.
I mean, it's my feeling that I want you to be that team that will find that kind of thing. It
's been a while since I
've had Rika Kitashima.
Standing position Eh, I
'll turn my hand.
Eh,
good morning again. It's
every time, but if it's out of order now, the tree that comes in is a system
.
Even if you can't hit it, it's called
Donmai Donmai, so
yes, yes, there was a cerebral infarction that will occur in 10 people this August
.
And I naturally said that I would live up to 100 in the figure where my wife died at 76
, but when we lived up to 100, 176
That's right, so
half and 88 Japanese and beige I'll see
my style  I don't go against the flow
, I think I'll remember it for a long time.
[Music]
ran
me me I think this is a stand for me.
I want to fly around, but
I bought a lot.
Poi jica author
Is it okay because I lost in advance
? The characteristic of the orchestra team that gets 10 points at the end is that I just lost.
This can be a lifetime
Komae goes up to the sky
Well, if you eat and divide it, it feels like a hard worker, but
eonon d
In our example, it's actually a mess that I ate at the next level of technology
.  I want to win Erogee
[Music]
If it's true, I'd like to quit my job and go to about 12-I don't
have the water supply even though it's the most solder.
Evaluation Day
Hu Yao Kuni Groom Stable
2 days I lied to the name of the day
Only on Wednesday I thought that the doctor
would do it as soon as possible and I would go to the scene with the first two.
Football is
the happiest in relieving stress.
[Applause]
Well, I haven't lived in the final league with such a quarterly applause,
so I'm not aiming for that case photo issue solo of our
team centered on technical college students and weapons yet.  Karane Balloon By the way, it seems that you haven't heard about the body of Hinohara-sensei's team
, so this tournament is centered around that balsan,
isn't it?
I
feel pressure love bird
ok ok You
said that the game will open first, so
ah ah ah good
good good I lost because of the salt title push
[Applause]
I don't lie down on the bench a little I want to do it once
I visited there.
T Let's meet, which was the last time?
There was a
mousse.  ]
ananan and others did their
best
hello world
[Music]
Boober
dejikame Hey, it's
cool
me
I wonder if I'm going to go there
none the Thank you so much me
mem
Leave it to Mr. of, who is a meat master.
Hmm nande
have no ano ne
ni
albania
[Music]
Hmm, I said a little
car
[Applause]
Wow Wow
The d 21 under the base is not b PET bottle a Rear
lined up
Boo Boo j It
has never fallen to a person
Grab the trolley The flow of the game has come to the balloon
[Music]
Go with this momentum  For example, there was a championship flag needle, but
I remembered that I would pay back the debt in the final, so eh
ah ah
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah ah  Don't forget the spirit of challenge as you say
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] What
's happening in my mind when I'm young is the iron I bought, the regret I lost, and
so on.  When it comes to our age,
I have this kind of image in my mind, so it's better than others.
It will be reproduced like this in the image again by
[Music]
true
want to do re
[Music]
Hmm